[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] أجنبي ،
فما الذي فعلناه خلال الاثني عشر
شهرًا الماضية فقط ، لقد أطلقنا
علب Aquafina ، لذا فهي عبارة عن
عبوات قابلة لإعادة التدوير بشكل لا نهائي ، لذا
فقد أطلقنا أيضًا
محطة مياه Aquafina كما هو الحال مع
يمكن للشراكة مع دبي أن
تأخذ الزجاجة القابلة لإعادة التعبئة التي أعلنا عنها أيضًا
مجموعة مكونة من 100
زجاجة بلاستيكية أكوافينا ، لذا هنا
الآن نقدم حلولاً إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وأجزاء أخرى من الشرق الأوسط من
شأنها أن تساعدنا على أن نصبح أكثر استدامة
وأكثر وعيًا بالبيئة
[موسيقى]
، الاختلاف في الشركات هو
أنها اختارت جميعًا أجزاء مختلفة من
سلسلة القيمة ، حيث تحدد كيف
يريدون معالجة تغليف العبوات
مشكلة كبيرة ، لذلك عالجت بعض الشركات
أنواعًا مختلفة من حلول التعبئة والتغليف
تناول طرق إعادة التدوير
وتحفيز الناس على
إعادة التدوير وركز بعضهم على
معالجة التغليف وكيفية الحصول على
كل شيء  ng خارج المكب
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية